[Music] citizens of the reject Nation it's
Christmas today it's Christmas today is it
today I think conceptually are they watching this
at midnight I don't know how they count it I don't
understand you open presents did Santa come Merry
Christmas holol Even if it's a day after Mary we
don't even know what's time what does it matter
it's the season of giving today is the day Jesus
was born scientifically speaking they woke up
he said what up Jesus ladies and gentlemen we
don't know the episode title that's how been going
into these is it about Jesus no what if Jesus was
in the MCU you know what to do uh leave a like
that would be very much appreciated also tell
us in the comments you've seen this episode
before we have what did you think about it
did you like it where would you rank it what
is your what if Christmas scenario subscribe
and click that notification get notified when
our reaction for the next episodes up on the
channel we are powering through them thank
you to pra for helping us edit down these
highlights you guys don't deserve a day off
thank you to all who have joined us at our
patreon page you comeing super sex to rejects or
there you get the full length reaction watchong
where you sync up with your own copy of what
if and John and I cover several things over
there exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included Kon you ready to all a good
night Heroes plucked from across different
realities previously on of all of them season
one but you don't know her story oh from the
daughter of a Mad Titan to the champion of a
multiversal war oh that's cool to becoming the
hero of her story began in someone else's they're
doing a continuation of a of an episode season
one that's an interesting all right all right
a a hidden sequel episode they're really
being ambitious and and bold with their
formatting yes ambitious I'm going to call
it ambitious with his home on the verge of
Destruction Tony Stark self-made Iron Man made
the ultimate Heroes play that's a different
universe that's hard Universe yeah that's not
the what universe but in this universe Tony
never made it her ah oh that's sad that
is dark Oh I thought they just killed him
off oh he lands with the uh we're goingon
to beet Jeff Goldblum again crap I'm dead
people at sakar the Grand Master Can't Be
Heaven uh I think that's sakar you're not
God yeah okay who wo W uh-oh fire
topaz the foam release the [Music]
[__] I think it was Overkill with the foam but
look he's still smoldering uh
no this is hell I've gone to
hell this is you this is you this is the guy Mr
metal Mojo man is in the palace oh this going to
be the Mad Max episode I think so yes the defeat
of Thanos and provocateur with the facial hair I
like what you're doing with defeater of
Thanos you know time works differently
here we've been talking about Mr metal Mojo
man's nuclear ride for for days possibly Tin
Man Rocket Man Mojo man it is okay the Mojo I
like that metal Mojo cuz you do have oh we won
good a some good heart she's okay she's okay
okay Mojo oh I like that attention of detail
there they gave him a moment I like it actually
give some nuance you got to stay and celebrate
with us it's my uh 21st 21st what birthday but
thanks but I kind of put my party days behind me
so spaceship is it uh that way whoever's
playing Iron Man does a great job really
solid uh will there be food like I can hear
where it's off but they nail the type of tone
and intonation the Rhythm Is there yeah
that's more important than a sound alike
celebrate two things me and and the SAR I
thought this was going to be Gamora story
oh yeah maybe she wins the race Valkyrie yay get
and hang like Mario Kart jump the go not yet not
yet it's fantastic oh my God corg
get out of here you crazy
[Applause] kid oh I love the sound design that
tast like a dog park surprise it's me I didn't
mean to Spook you or did I I did I did that
must be him I think it's Jeff goia yep you
got it nailed it yeah well this would be
called a chariot race Formula 1 this is
Intergalactic NASCAR uh race cars are similar
but very different common mistake don't be
embarrassed whoa going on Zack Snider on
us damn grandm and Tony Stark interacting
good call delightful that's what you use
Whata if for the things that we can never
have woo cool it's like ready player one yeah
whoa offense someone with the celestial face
celestials but small fitting
end for who was that this is
horrifying H that old trick
you look dazzled by her
Tony you're going to miss the best part
hey throw the tin cans at [Applause] her
o I'd like to see you old drive isn't this
a touch barbaric no that's part of the joy
of it it's like a gladiator battle are those
pamsters topz chinam Cal your cheeks we used
to throw rotten food but given the recent
famines leaving people uh how do I put this
peckish peckish if you liked my chinchillas
you're going to love my Champion release the
champion oh who's it going to be this [Music]
corg what who is this this guy there he is
[Music] nothing it's actually a great shot
bro no here's the best part oh no so much for
staying for one drink oh you're doing the thing
he's doing the thing I do miss the suit UPS cuz
now it's all like uh why is it sticky nanot
Tech yeah and it's all smooth and liquid not
suie the extremist era not the same
you to think this through Tony [Music]
Valkyrie do that Gamora yeah it supposed to
be a Gamora story yeah Gamora yeah does he
build her a hot rod cuz Tony's whole
thing was like hot rods and cars gun
aler oh cuz she's
Thanos she would be on thanos's side after the
events so like this would be an actual fight who
are you you're death thank you very very much
you've ruined my birthday that's sarcasm the
first part not the second part perfect I feel
like valky is attracted to Gamora oh woke perk
of having an arc reactor in your chest why are
you trying to kill me daughter of Thanos the
one burdened to bring balance to this universe
daughter of Thanos he doesn't know about Thanos
yet right right CU Avengers all right ready
to ride roll I had to say that at least once
not you stabby he sensed it remember he had
that feeling and we saw him turn around at
the end of Avengers but he didn't have a name
for him all right wait for my signal say no
more I love that just made him a Hulk oh
Tony Tony Tony you blinked on no planet
is that a signal Tony I thought I
saw your goatee twitch no Tony you
blinked she got to gun you again would
you glare your way out of that cell oh
it'll take take more than laser prooof glass
to Rob Thanos of his victory pick a new song
The Way theyve edited I can't tell if these guys
recorded in the same booth or not because they
they've edited them together really well at
least the comedic timing is real yeah did we
date or something what your dad got against me
you destroyed his tatari New York your Victory
might have been glorious but it will also be
short people died I lost a friend do you know
what it's like to see your home world destroyed
she knows she knows she knows she more than most
almost brought to its knees by a mad man
you're saying all the things there won't
be a next time he's talking to Terence Howard
next time baby Mojo man he's not the hero we
hope he's a very nasty nasty man put down your
dinner I mean that is if you got food is this
Grandmaster guy as bad as my gut says he is he
use me as a paper weight just have to sit on
paper which is my nemesis the running theme
of paper rock and then I'm going after your
dad how did she get out her story of Gamora is
before her Avengers episode in what season one
right yes it have to be look at this little thing
I think I'll name him NCO after my friend Jeffrey
you're the revengers yeah you were in a Death
Race here to explain I was going to win sure
you were what happened to last year's winner oh
he went to live on a farm with the other winners
you want the thrill to feel alive so you can
forget whatever mistake has you chasing that
demon in a bottle demon in the bottles the Iron
Man story where he's an alcoholic that's clever
cuz we're going to beat the grandmas at his own
game what do you say it is cool to hear Tony Stark
say demon in the bottle and thanks for that Mar
I'm seeing the character of just Tony Stark and
not just like some what if came yeah hey did
I try any silly stuff that is the silly stuff
yeah more montages building stuff we didn't get
to see Valkyrie and Tony interact huh what's cool
is that it does feel like they've brought Tony
St to life you know and I'm getting I feel like
I'm getting my wish fulfillment of Tony yeah
you shouldn't be here you should be running
ever hear of Campground rules always leave a
place better than you found it but since it's
an made it and it's not Downy it doesn't feel
like it sacrifices our universes yeah exactly
people creatures beings of SAR have seen enough
Insanity here's my offer me you One race winner
takes the planet bad pack I'm intrigued but
not sold you pick the Chariots sir there's no
reason to do this H up don't be such a logic
Linda logic Linda if I win I get that suit
uh deal you're racing too mopet of Thanos it's
daughter of Thanos daughter really I'll stick
to that story too they set this up I was going to
be the one part that's kind of lacking for me in
this episode is they set up as like a Gamora
origin of that version of her yeah and it's
doesn't feel like that at all well I that's
the third act I'm assuming but definitely not
what it felt like like I like the episode but
excuse like what we it's why have that in the
opening yeah yeah like what a roundabout way to
be like and Iron Man landed here like just do
that come to take this off me depends still
going to kill me that's what I thought here
let's keep in touch have a nice summer this is
what I like I really feel like I'm watching Iron
Man again it's actually pretty exciting it's
pretty exciting yeah for me wait for my queue
[Music] go
cool now nice very Mad Max use
a little the doof Warrior take
that nice cool corg is like the
heart of the Season he really
is yeah oh great tracking shot damn that's so
much fun there's like a cool action shot in
every episode yeah they really deed this
season it's actually got flavor who are
you cuz all I hear about is your father
I'm a murderous thank you yeah yeah that
was yesterday what about today what
about right now it's a great question
okay so they are tied in koi okay it's
coming back I told you third act here we
are Rainbow Road celestials mouth
[Music] tongue ouchie [Music] what
is this tire the tires The Chariot
yeah this makes no sense how do
you see oh you're alive never
been happier oh hold up there lady
Grinch could use a little help hold
up how does he see I don't know I can't get it
oh no no no no no no no fly Commander another
Chariot turn into a hot rod yeah that's what I
wanted that was cool there is what I wanted
that is awesome that was awesome I was want
hot rod this whole time like an action figure
he just transform go to Target and you get
like an Iron Man car they need many toys of
this that's all I wanted now I'm happy I was
that was my my only negative and now I'm good
I'm so [Music] good I love how they kept that
kind of 80s sci-fi synth music yeah like sakar
had in the movie I lived in my dad's Shadow for
a long time I did stuff I'm not proud of people
died because of who I was and what I fil I like
how they they have this attention to detail the
characters great but I'm not my father you're not
your father I made a choice for the better and I
became Iron Man you mean Mr metal Mojo oh I see
that sticking I feel like the characterization
of our leads that we've known for three phases
is better here than in Phase 4 in the live
action cuz Thor didn't feel like Thor and like
Doctor Strange didn't either oh beautiful right
like like the writing here is so good to these
[Applause]
characters oh [Music] uh anyway you get
to decide who you want to be not your
father not your past you decide who
are you why safe my name is [Music]
Gamora why is [Music]
Gamora wow destroying Titans that was cool
is that Dutch Swedish mayy this isn't over
Stark golden red hot roded making me so
happy oh and she's going to win and then she'll be
the queen of the planet so Tony can leave ah yes
yes I was wondering why Valkyrie had to race but
it's so she can win and that way she's a leader
of new valky and new Asgard all over again oh no
that was wronged wronged wrong I'm winning I'm
[Music] winning yeah that's right American
Innovations 180 mph excellent [Applause]
shot the tow ring Play Dirty
there it is [Music] yeah Iron Man
powered awesome awesome he had to hit the NOS yeah
he did it too soon Junior that's a 10-second car
great it's got the SAR markings but
it's Iron Man I think there's like
actually great technical achievements in
this for animation for Marvel a tie and
as the rulle St the choice of winner
comes down to me I choose me get boo
[Music]
boo hey I like it o that feels good viscous oh
he smells like bad Life Choices it was smart to
make Grand Master the actual villain of this
yeah and they finally like killed the what
if character hey she's still the one celebrated
hey and she's going to be taking down the Tyrant
she's going to be asgard's new Asgard Queen and
she's doing the walk I think they just cred you
their King what do you say about the being
special counsel to the king yep okay I'll do
that so close to home his Odyssey almost at
an end except oh I can't return to my father
Without You Stark it's not the punches thrown but
the people that change the outcome of the battle
what you never failed to amaze me little one
you're the one they call Iron Man what someone
finally got your name right let's do this G
it's knowing someone has your back in a fight
I'm
melting all right I don't know how I feel
about the Thanos Saga being n and void by
a single attack but I mean that's what what if
does that's true that's you got to carry on the
what if tradition you're not wrong you know
what other tradition people should carry on
What's That getting themselves some RR apparel
this the space babies of the Galaxy or Marvel
inspired shirt Coy's got a whole bunch of shirts
and he's choosing to pull out that one that I'm
already wearing and flashed on camera and look
pull that one you know here's just some photos
on screen because we got like our you know Pedro
Pascal space babies of the Galaxy Coy I'm trying
to shout out whoa whoa oh I'm so glad you're
here hey could you find a bucket bucket and a mop
sponge me sponge me up I need to be absorbed by
something looks handrawn that was fantastic gross
looks like cheese oh I like that last one it's the
house of the Dragon one my favorite of the Game of
Thrones yeah these were all handpicked by Greg for
me for Christmas yeah buddy we also got our Pedro
Pascal one that everyone loves so much and a whole
bunch of other ones and we saw some Marvel apparel
as well but yeah guys it's personally my favorite
way you can go ahead and supp support the channel
you look good while doing it and we're involved
with all the designs as well what do you think
of the episode it was all the fun of uh of the
Christmas one for me but with a little bit more
story like it felt more like an important issue
like sometimes in comics issues are fun and they
serve the purpose of like entertaining but you
know it's not going to really be like referenced
So when you say issue you mean like comic book
isue yeah yeah not like mental issue yeah like
like like an issue of comics um I do find that
like the fun ones sometimes don't feel like they
further their plot and that's that's okay like
it doesn't bother me but this episode felt like
an actual what if universe that there could be a
sequel to this felt like an issue that had some
weight tying into other issues while also having
the fun of the Christmas one so I think this and
the Christmas one are almost like tied for me
because I didn't love the very very ending um
but Greg brought up an immediately good point
in that it is like a what if where that is a
great way to give it stakes and and tie things in
together and make it have import but um I liked
that the bookends served that purpose where it
was like how does this really get to Gamora and
then you're like oh I'm shocked they're bringing
them and then like it was a bit of a twist it was
a bit of a surprise so I liked it I forget what
the setup is of that Gamora in the opening is is
oh yeah I forget is she like is her thing that
she killed her dad is that like her her setup
with the character they're not fighting Thanos
it's been three years it's been a while right
it's been a long time since what if season 1 yeah
I don't remember also do you remember when they
announced what if season two they said everything
was going to relate to phase four and they were
like everything from fa like remember they said
season one was all of phase 1 through three and
then they're like season two really focused
on phase four none of these have been about
phase four yet no not at all I wonder if they
like completely changed their plan after it's a
good call because uh so far it's way better than
season one I'm loving this so much it's so much
better than season one I agree I I think on on
every level in terms of what I've really wanted
them to do was utilize animation you know like
when I watch The Incredibles for the first time
I remember thinking oh at the time of of when
The Incredibles came out what they were doing
with demonstrating these superhero Powers their
overall prowess you could only do an animation at
the time and make it feel believable because you
are being in the medium of Animation as opposed
to watching live action and watching this Jos of
something that feels like a cartoon CGI thing and
here they're actually utilizing that with their
camera angles with a lot of these great shots
that might look a little bit wonky in live action
especially with the time they all lot for their
visual effects artist a lot of the time and yeah
and pay so yeah I think that what they've been
doing here like with the car racing sequences that
have this like Mad Max Mario Kart bit of like uh
in in the Star War I don't even watch it but the
Star Wars like animated shows like tales of the
Jedi it's not pod racing there some called Riot
racing I think is what it called why would they
she pod race I mean it's cuz it's a different
kind of thing but it's the same thing kind of
thing like a baric type of pod racing and and is
sort of the uh vibe that I have here but like they
have these sweeping angles and precision on their
editing that I absolutely adore but that all can
be still I I think that could all be null and void
if you don't have an interesting story and I think
what they are doing really well the only one that
kind of let me down a tad bit has been episode
2 this one I thought it was so smart to have the
whole thing with the heart of like missing pepper
at the very top that way they're reminding the
audience like no we haven't forgotten about the
characterization of what point in time we are with
this guy and what would Tony be feeling I felt
like I was actually watching Tony start Carry
On from that first Avengers movie we got Iron
Man back and it wasn't in a way that I felt like
sacrificed the Iron Man sacrifice yeah and that's
so you mean I've talked about that at nauseum I'm
I'm tired of mentioning my issues with bringing
back them multiv yeah Multiverse things it doesn't
you don't bring back the the actor because your
brain's not going to go that's not my Tony Stark
you're going to go Robert Tony Jr is Iron Man and
this is managing because it's a different medium
to feel like Iron Man and feel like the spirit of
Downey Jr brings us back to Avengers one yeah it's
so good it's really well done and the way they pay
attention to their characters of How would how
would grandmas interact with Tony Stark or vice
versa how would Tony Stark interact with Valkyrie
how would he respond to to cor I really feel like
they I get the impression the writers actually
love the characters they are portraying here you
know what at the least they watch them at the very
least they watch them I feel like these people
watched all of w Division I get the impression
they actually like the characters because they
feel accurately portrayed from the movies which
is the difference for me from what if season 1
to what if season 2 exactly what if season 1 felt
like they were making an MCU thing to make it and
season two has felt like the comic books where
it's like a writer that loves a character has
a weird take they want to play with that won't be
in they they felt like the very definition not all
the time but some of the time a good amount of
the time I would say of when they were bringing
over like a character when they're bringing over
like a storyline or continuity from a movie I'm
not talking like strange Supreme which is like a
very different that's a very very different take
you know um I'm talking about whenever they would
cut to Tony Stark in season one it would often
felt like a cameo or some type of caricature it
didn't feel like a caricature and this felt like a
character and I I found myself getting lost in it
and just believing I'm watching Tony Stark again
and I think the depth of Animation heightening is
allowing a little bit more imersive cuz like we're
like more in like this animation is stunning it's
so much better and I don't know how people think
it's the same because it's it's the same style but
it's night and day for me more immersive it's the
same same thing you say about into the spider vers
AC cross SPID vers it's the same style but it's
one's more defined and Rich and and more depth
they've Advanced it with that time and it makes a
world of difference I'm in love with this season I
think this is going to be you know if if they keep
going at like you know 1 three and four caliber
two is not bad but like two feels more like season
one yeah uh if they keep going at this level this
will be in my like second third like I I see the
Marvel the quality as like you know first tier is
for me like winter soldier guardians Guardians 3
Spider-Man um three but then tier two is the good
stuff like you know the the captain America first
avenger the the stuff that's like solid but I I
don't find myself re-watching it as much and then
there's the stuff that I've I've been like oh no
we're falling like things have gone ay like your
love and thunder like your uh in my case Doctor
Strange and to me this is going to land right in
that sweet like second tier of like this is really
good I'm so actually glad it exists it emboldens
these characters I won't watch it as often but I'm
really glad it's here yeah I think I think uh the
one and wonder which one I might rank this about
the Christmas one yeah you got really into the
Downey of it I was surpr I [__] love Christmas
that honestly that honestly surprised the hell out
of me how great um how great of a job I thought
they did with getting Tony Stark whoever voicing
him has to has to go past an impression right
because they can't just play a Downey they have to
play Tony which is not Downey yeah I liken it to
when a character makes like when Kevin Conor had
to do Batman or when um Yuri has to be Spider-Man
you know they have to really make it their own
they might have their Inspirations and it might
be but it has to be their character but it has to
be their character and then even though they're
like yeah we have to have you be the Robert dony
junor version yeah and this one he's harder spot
because he's got to be playing the universes blank
as his own he's not just showing up to do a few
lines right which is like you know Josh broland
show off for one line cool that was exciting but
like that was this is a full Arc but they had this
guy show up and I imagine as the same actor to
do lines in the first season and he has to be
a full on character who's ing this episode with
purpose and intention and motivation you know what
you're right I think that slightly Inspire other
characters I'm going to put that slightly above
Christmas now too so for me it's 1 four3 two and
oh yeah yeah me too yeah I think the Dynamics were
great too between him and Valkyrie and grandm
being like an an actual villain as opposed to
just like a funny Jeff Goldblum guy I got I got to
see the character of grandmas versus I was watch
you're just watching Jeff go like like it's you
love him but you're also like Jeff you're happy
Jeff goblins here also the valkyrie element you
brought up during the episode I really enjoy that
we got some demon in the bottle as an external
reference and this is when he's still drinking
so he had those drinks but I love that they're
acknowledging how similar those characters are
parallel so yeah this is my second favorite
episodes I agree with you now I think the part
and even him connecting with do you hear that COI
do you hear when you're doing that you hear how
[__] annoying the people love it you're just
so comfortable you're going to scratch away at
your microphone how you guys doing it's Christmas
you can hear it can't you can't you hear it how's
your Christmas we have the same mic have the
same headphones just hanging could hear it can
you this is what happens when we're this deep
someone has a la mic and they're scratching
away at just hanging out this is what inevitably
happen I'm trying to talk is that Us Frozen is
that Us Frozen that's how long we've been
screen recording um and and with uh Gamora
they even acknowledged the charact even as I was
watching it I was like you just keep bringing up
her father that's her only character and then
the show the episode I was like oh that's the
point that's all she talks about who are you
and how Tony Stark has affected her identity
excellent yeah this is all the stuff we've been
having problems with the movies not doing and I
and I and I hate to keep taking Jabs at some of
the movies but it is why we can't just go oh it's
fine it's a blockbuster oh it's fine it's a Marvel
movie yeah people that don't even realize why they
aren't enjoying it as much yeah this is what we're
missing it's these relationships it's knowing the
characters it's how they relate to each other it's
the metaphors for your own life while watching it
a lot of that is missing and it's been replaced
with some of the stuff that's more heavy-handed
that isn't Landing so this is delightful and a
lot of the time I find myself kind of sinking
into my chair because I'm like ah damn it they're
going to be doing what I don't like about what if
season one and then they don't and then they turn
they don't yeah then I'm like oh they actually
they acknowledge so I feel like they actually
Beyond just improving their animation it really
seems like they learned their lesson on what went
wrong with a lot of the storytelling to not make
it impactful and I hope the word of mouth on
this movie spreads and people real on the on
the show spreads and people are like oh you know
what this season's actually worth people's time
because and I do think the day and date release
is good I now that I'm seeing them like this is
exciting to watch every day yeah I know or all
at once when you have cuz you have to cuz you got
to edit them and have them release day day yeah
that too just us in a cage for 5 hours all righty
guys what do what four I think it was four all
right guys well thank you so much for being here
subscribe leave a like Merry Christmas what do you
think about this episode see us for [Music] five